Raquel Levis comes clean and apologizes
to Ariana Maddox amid allegations she
had a months-long affair with Tom
Sandoval on Wednesday the reality star
spoke out about the Scandal for the
first time in an exclusive statement to
ET I want to apologize for my actions
and my choices foremost to Ariana there
is no excuse I am not a victim and I
must own my actions and I deeply regret
hurting Ariana Raquel's apology comes
just days after news broke that she's
been having an affair with her co-star
Sandoval who has been dating Ariana for
nine years we have a lot of respect for
each other
so I think that's really important
Raquel was previously engaged to another
Vanderpump rule star James Kennedy but
the two called it quits at the end of
2021. James wanted to be friends right
away and that was just something that I
I couldn't do emotionally but I feel
like we've gotten to a place in our
lives now where we can be friends Raquel
caused controversy on the current season
of the Bravo show for kissing the other
Tom Tom Schwartz following his divorce
from Katie Maloney I'm just trying to
live my life and I'm sorry if that
offends people but it's not going to
stop me from doing what I want to do now
Raquel says she's reflecting on her
choices talking to a counselor and
learning things about herself like
patterns of codependency and addiction
to being and feeling loved I have sought
emotional validation through intimate
connections that are not healthy without
regard for my own well-being sometimes
negatively affecting others and often
prioritizing the intimate connection sin
over my friendships the reality star
says she's taking the steps to
understand her behavior and make
healthier choices and while she doesn't
expect sympathy understanding or
forgiveness she is striving to be a
better person moving forward this year I
kind of did a deep dive and really
opened myself up and experienced new
things being single and just kind of
like living it up to the fullest a
source tells ET that Raquel tried to
apologize to Ariana privately on Friday
after news of the affair broke Ariana
responded to Raquel but wasn't ready to
receive the apology The Source adds that
Raquel also tried to apologize on
Wednesday before releasing her statement
but didn't hear back from Ariana news of
Raquel and Sandoval's Affair first broke
last week with a source telling ET that
there have been too many instances where
Ariana felt like he disrespected her and
she finally ended things Sandoval issued
his own statement on Instagram Tuesday
apologizing to Ariana revealing his
biggest regret is that he Dishonored her
I always feel like whenever I'm not with
him whenever I come back to him it's
like
okay like it's like that it's almost
like a relief feeling meanwhile another
source told E.T that the incident has
created a major split in the group with
almost everyone against Sandoval and
Raquel never liked that guy and now it
feels good to have everyone else feel
the same way I do if you're in Orange
County okay and you're planning on
seeing Tom Sandoval on the most extra
strike don't forget to bring the
tomatoes and the Cabbage okay I stand
Ariana this is in real time
I love you so much I love you the girls
are rallying around Ariana but no in
time she'll be okay